Margery Taylor green had a better line
of questioning against Hunter Biden so
much so that he stormed out of the
capital chair recognize Miss Green from
Georgia for five
minutes thank you Mr chairman uh excuse
me Hunter apparently you're afraid of my
word
here
oh I like to reclaim my time Mr chairman
burst their
bubble wow that's too bad
M Rec from T I think it's clear and
obvious for everyone watching this
hearing today that Hunter Biden is
terrified of strong Conservative
Republican women because he can't even
face my words as I was about to speak to
him what a coward no he's afraid of
going to prison and getting caught for
being the bagman for the family and
pedling American influence and making
tens of millions of dollars that's
that's what he's afraid of he's not
afraid of women Hunter Biden might be
afraid of a lot of stuff he ain't afraid
of women